okay that is self-explanatory right it
should be quittin bull in trading
function dysentery we'll see what it
means as the talk was wrong this is
joint work with my student Baris who's
there
all questions should be directed to him
the slides are thanks to him any
mistakes or even due to me and thanks
for sticking around for the last day so
let me tell you what what problem we
look at and I'm talking a little bit
about why you might care about it okay
so let's say you have a bunch of points
these are on the unit sphere and D
dimensions there's some function Phi
that says okay if you have a bunch of
points the unit sphere inner products
are between plus 1 and minus 1 the
function Phi that takes inner product of
two points and maps at a real number
that's my function Phi now we have a
query Y which is also a point of the
unit sphere okay I set up what do we
want to do well you want to compute a
function that looks like this so you
want to sum over all the points in your
collection
thank you next to xn take the point X I
take the inner product with a query y
apply Phi to it take exponential and sum
up over the endpoints ok it sounds like
a weird thing why would you want to do
that well hopefully I'll try to convince
you why you might care about a problem
like this but that's the problem we're
gonna try to solve okay all right
so well actually let me certain so now
let me tell me why you might care about
this kind of problem so you know this
this function which is sum of
Exponential's of inner products right
now just you know if you want to think
of what fire is just to think of fire
being the identity or firing a linear
function okay well we'll try to put more
complicated functions in there but for
starters just to motivate just think
about Phi being just a linear function
okay so this is the sum of Exponential's
of inner products well if you have a
data set this is this particular
function is something called the
partition function in physics is a term
that arose in physics in the physical
picture this is a certain this arises
from a certain model that says that the
probability distribution the the weight
of the distribution on X I is
proportional to exponential in inner
product okay and this is the normalizing
constant for that distribution if you
know the normalizing constant it tells
you exactly what probably my super and
every point that's why the term
partition function sort of partitions
the probability mass so this partition
function arises in a number of different
settings let me try to give you some
settings where you might you might
encounter this okay so the first problem
is something called kernel density
estimation so there's a lot of jargon in
this title let me tell you what it's a
very simple thing really so the setup is
the following it's something that arose
in nonparametric statistics you have a
bunch of points they're drawn from some
distribution D and what you'd like to do
is figure out what's the mass that this
distribution places on a new point y so
it seems difficult to answer this
question you don't know this
distribution is the various approaches
to answering this question one approach
says let's assume our distribution is of
a certain form I try to learn what this
distribution might be from
we have and now we extrapolate the
nonparametric view says let's try to not
assume too much over the distribution
and still let's try to extrapolate and
one method that people do to doing this
is to say well roughly speaking what we
want to do is you want to take our
discrete distribution on the data set
and sort of smooth it out so we want to
sort of smooth it out so a discrete
distribution is is really too pointy
right it's it peaks at points when the
data set has 0 everywhere else you want
to go to smooth out this mass it's a
natural thing to do and one way to
smooth out the mass is to put a little
Gaussian distribution or some other
function that you like around each of
these point muscles an average ok you
think about what this Gaussian
distribution is doing well it's actually
a function of the form that I described
before it's exponential in some function
of the inner product and you know this
kind of method is used for outlier
detection for clustering and so on so
outer direction what you'd like to do is
given a new point why you'd like to tell
you know is this something that I expect
to see or is it an unusual point or is
it a typical point and this is not
appointed I've seen before roughly
speaking of its close to things that
you've seen before then you think of it
as typical if it's far away you'll think
of it as a new row and this is a way to
actually put a number on that and say
yeah here's a value
yeah so typically yes you'd want to
renormalize now in our case the
normalizing constant won't really matter
so in our case these functions that I'm
summing up I'm gonna read I'm gonna re
wait so that the maximum value is 1
but yeah I'm typical in typical cases
you'd want to renormalize
you'll multiply everything by a constant
okay it won't matter for us any any
other questions okay so so what problem
do we want to solve this is this is a
simple problem right there are n points
in your database you want to sum this up
what's the big deal okay so of course
you can you can compute this exactly
what we'd like to do is we'd like to
figure out is it possible to pre-process
the set of points beforehand so that
we're now ready to answer a bunch of
queries very very quickly okay so
imagine setting where you have your data
set you get some time to organize your
thoughts put everything together and now
a bunch of queries come at you and
you've gotta be able to answer these
queries quickly again and we what we'd
like to do is not spend linear time in
actually answering these queries so of
course you can go over the entire day
there is that and sum up these
quantities or take linear time can we do
better than that okay that's the problem
okay why do we care about it well of
course because we're in the real time
decision-making program so that's why we
care about this kind of problem okay I
had to put the title of the program
somewhere so that's where I okay so let
me know a little bit more about why you
know where such kinds of problems arise
arise I mean if you ask me too many
questions about these applications I'm
not going to be able to answer them but
even so I will bravely tell you about
what these applications are okay all
right so one kind of setup that arises
in machine learning is where you have
points and labels okay think of our
points as points in three-dimensional
space and the labels are plus 1 minus 1
what we'd like to do is
classifier in this case just a
separating hyperplane okay that
separates the red points which are
labeled plus 1 minus 1 from the blue
points which have exactly the opposite
table right one way to to do this sort
of thing is to say well let's design
some kind of loss function
okay center of penalty term that says
the following so we have these points
and we have labels plus 1 minus 1 let's
reflect all of the points let's multiply
them by the labels so we have the right
hyperplane all of our signed points
should be on one side of the hyperplane
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
take the the normal to this to this
hyperplane look at the sign point and
have some kind of loss function that
tells us how well we're doing with
respect to this particular sponsor must
sum up over all cost functions and you
might try to have you know sort of
figure out what this hyper lane should
be one way to do this is to do
stochastic gradient descent okay so
there are all cuz there's all sorts of
expertise about how you design loss
functions one kind of loss function is
the so called logistic loss function
which has this particular form and if
you do this the gradient of this loss
function at the contributions gradient
at this point the norm of that has this
particular form
so what you'd like to do in this sort of
setting is you're getting your gradient
from a sum of terms right you'd like to
estimate the gradient the question is
can you estimate the gradient quickly by
sampling points in your collection of
course you can get a good saw a good
estimate of the gradient by just so the
gradient is a sum over all the points
right the whole idea of stochastic
gradient descent is to not compute the
full gradient but actually just sample a
point now you could ask the question
well maybe some points are contributing
more to the gradient than others could
you actually do better by sampling them
in some biased way and yes you can in
the same kinds of issues arise so again
you're faced with a similar problem to
the kinds of problem that I was alluding
to earlier yeah so I I did I didn't say
this I'm gonna assume that here in fact
I have all points when unit sphere
actually sum of I won't say this but
I'll mention a result that we can
actually we can sort of reduce in some
sense too
from the general case to the unit case
but for our talk for this talk you know
everything will be on the unit sphere
yes exercise I shall say actually what
you could do is you can subsample the
points in some say and just work with
the sample okay
even so you could ask the question do
you need the full sample or not can you
actually do do things in time that is
better than the song so you absolutely
right in sometimes the point is the the
set of points the total number of points
doesn't really matter what matters is
you know a small representative or from
this distribution but even that you
could ask could you do better than the
entire sample other questions right yeah
like do you want to excite closest to
why this kind of very computation you
want the most violated example or
something together
why and then you want the one fathers
right so you're right what you're
pointing out is that you know this
function Phi that you have changes
things quite a bit in some cases you
might care about points that are nearby
in other cases you might care about
points that are far away so you know
thinking about I mean usually we think
of our nearest neighbor search and so on
where it's the points that are nearby
that affect us the most all kernel
density estimation the points are nearby
factors the most but here it might be
the case that we're getting most of our
contribution from stuff that's some
other distance and so how do we get at
that that's absolutely right and that's
where that's why having this function
Phi to transform the inner product
changes the nature of the problem quite
a bit
all right so you know we already seen a
few examples kernel density estimation
another another example is in an
optimization you might want to minimize
the maximum of a bunch of loss functions
and one way I mean the maximum is not a
very nice function it's often it's quite
common to take sort of a smooth version
of the maximum and one way to take a
smooth version a maximum is to take sum
of Exponential's take log of that okay
and this smooth max again has this form
that that we're looking at all right is
it is yet another yet another example
suppose we had a following model okay we
had a model where our points are points
in the hypercube d dimensional hypercube
we have a parameter vector Y okay Y is
on the unit sphere or on the our radius
our sphere okay and we have a density on
this thing which is exponential in inner
product divided by normalizing constant
okay and again we might want to compute
this normalizing constant because if you
want to do anything interesting with
this kind of model like we want to
sample a point from this model or we
want to estimate the gradient or we want
to test a hypothesis given these points
e10 ZM are they drawn from y1 or y2
right which is which is the which is the
parameter for all of these things you
might want to might care about actually
computing this normalizing constancy of
Y and questions can you do this sort of
thing in time which is better than
summing up over all the to the D points
trivia in time could be because this is
just a product of factors in each each
of the excise so you would need some
kind of xixj and turn to me I see it
could be possible but then I'm going to
say maybe I should have complicated them
all a little bit and put a Phi of X Y in
there which would complicate things so
you may be right
no harm censure but yeah so think about
let's say quadratic right and then what
would you do the questions
all right so let me tell you a little
bit about what we know about these kinds
of things so let me actually come to the
point that you made which is you have a
large collection of points what really
matters is this distribution and maybe
you don't need all of these points right
so let's say that so I said we're gonna
have this function Phi that takes inner
products and maps and toriel numbers
let's let's say L of Phi is this is a
Lipschitz constant will express
everything in terms of L of Phi okay now
our domain is plus 1 minus 1 lips a
constant L so the maximum value in the
minimum value are separated by 2 times R
okay all right so now our function is of
the form e to the power of 5 Phi applied
to the inner product let me normalize so
the maximum value is 1
ok so now all my values are in the range
eetu the power of minus 2l + 1 that's
the range of ministry and I'm let's say
I'm averaging this over the entire data
set so I values Y or Y is also in this
range so one natural way to do this
would be just random sample ok so just
random sample and try to estimate what G
of Y is okay that's the first thing you
would try well so if you try to figure
this out and say how many samples do you
need in order to get a good estimate you
need about if the right answer is mu mu
is now some number in this range you
would need 1 over mu samples to get a
good estimate
reason is well it could be okay you just
think about it it's not that hot it
could be that all of your mass is coming
from one point all of your contribution
is really coming from one point
everything else
sorry all the contribution is coming
from new fraction of the of the points I
didn't getting zero everywhere else even
to hit this new fraction you need a
sample 1 over nu x and then if you want
to get a high probability estimate with
high you know with low error you need
the 1 over epsilon squared log 1 over
Delta terms ok so this means that you
can actually ignore the you know the
entire data set in this sub sample and
just work with that sub shop so
henceforth will actually assume that our
n we've already done this step as a pre
process so our n effectively is e to the
power of 2 L of Phi ok why is that
because you know in order to do so this
method is saying that we need number of
samples which is roughly 1 over mu well
1 over mu is kind of the answer that we
want to compute what's the smallest
possible value of Nu we said the
smallest possible value is e to power
minus 2l so that's our the size of our
sample so that's our setup and indeed if
we have such a sample and we can we can
compute the right value now the question
is can we do better than this
can we do better than n in this setting
right all right so there's been some
work on this and this is all working on
the practical side let me tell you are
one one particular piece of work which
is sort of quite close to sort of the
methods that we use so this is work by
Mossman and Armand in ICML 2016 and what
they said is the following so they use
the interesting method which has been
using a few papers on partition function
estimation and this was sort of in the
linear case when you know it's e to the
Phi inner product so that Phi is a
linear function
so what they show is that this is very
clever trick from probability called
Gumbel distribution Gumbel random
variables and they use this trick
this method of Gumbel random variables
to somehow reduce the estimation of this
partition function to maximum inner
product search so somehow they transform
this problem so that now what they have
is a bunch of vectors and what we want
to do is just figure out what's the
maximum inner product of the query
vector with these vectors it's all their
transform the problem is this inner
product search question and then for
this inner product search question they
apply nearest neighbor search kind of
nearest neighbor search that they need
to do is fairly accurate okay so they
need nearest neighbor search with this
kind of parameter it's for those of you
who know that what this means this means
that you're not guaranteed to produce
the exactly and its neighbor if you but
you're guaranteed to produce the exact
nearest neighbor to within this fudge
factor in the distances again this is a
pretty small fudge factor so you know
empirically that they show this performs
very well in fact what they show is that
they need only root and queries to their
nearest neighbor data structure so
that's great but the flipside is that on
the in the worst case if you actually
apply the best theoretical bounds to
what you know what what would give you
this kind of error guarantee is the
query time is basically linear it's like
n to the power of 1 minus some function
of Epsilon ok so that's basically what's
not alright that's sort of the closest
in terms of prior work we said what do
we show so what we show is that if you
have any any convex function Phi we're
going to express everything in terms of
the Lipschitz constant so we can design
a data structure where the
pre-processing time in space is
basically linear times exponential in
the Lipschitz constant and then there is
the other epsilon square and log 1 over
Delta terms and to answer any query why
we spend time which is proportional to 1
over square root ok so remember earlier
we random sampling was spending 1 over
mu we can do it in 1 over square root
mean there is a space key additional
factor okay and this factor is
non-trivial it's exponential in roughly
Lipschitz constant raised to 2/3 so I
want to give you an idea of what what's
actually involved in proving this result
not really gonna get into all of the
details but my goal is just give you a
high-level overview of what goes into
what I don't take into consideration
viewpoint so we have a hash table based
data structure as we'll see
so in fact you could throw in those new
points into the into the hash table as
well ok so yes it should be possible to
update we don't have any you could throw
new points into your data structure so
we're assuming that we have a random
sample and we're building so you can
sort of maintain a random sample of the
points of seen so far when a new point
comes in you use reservoir sampling and
then you throw them into your hash table
so yes you could actually update but for
the talk I'm going to say we just have a
static thing to the minus 5 and minus 5
5.45 like I'll flip fight no I'll flip
the sine of Phi to make it whatever yeah
you could take any fire you want I mean
if you want oh I say yes yes yes so it's
gonna like decreasing or increasing
Lydia's finally still complex but yeah
could be also
close or far away points depending on
the other slope it doesn't have to be
increasing in being a product or
decreasing in enterprise but yeah if you
don't you're not monitored then it
should be somehow like that which means
the boundaries yeah yeah the boundaries
are the difficult things to get other
questions
by the way how much time okay alright
okay just to just to compare this to
what we've what I've said before again
I'm gonna use the assumption that n my
number of points is exponential in the
Lipschitz constant because I of the
reason I said before mu is 1 over N sort
of the minimum value of MU is where our
results look the worst so random
sampling here would take order of n sway
just wraps and all of the points and the
query time would be order of n this data
structure based on maximum inner product
search worst case has quadratic almost
quadratic space and almost linear time
although in practice this actually works
well I have to say the experiment show
and in our case we get something like n
to the three-halves and it's quite all
right
and you know what kinds of things would
be applied to don't worry about these
these columns let's read this one you
could think of just an exponential in a
product you could think of the Gaussian
you could think of these polynomial
functions and other functions like this
so you would apply various kinds of
transformations to inner products by a
method and then you got to figure out
what the you know what the fire is and
what the Lipchitz constant is and read
what that means for our result ok and I
eyes mention this briefly I said for the
talk we'll think of all of our points as
being a unit sphere or sphere scaled by
harm but in fact you can you can reduce
Euclidean space to this unit sphere
setting by sort of a fairly standard
technique and this technique is used by
Antoni in residence time for example
also you know we're gonna actually sum
sum up real valued numbers we're
computing a thing which is the sum of
three large numbers you might want to
compute vector sums okay it turns out
that if you want to compute vector sums
you can reduce that in some sense to
computing the sum of the norms of the
vectors and if you can do some of the
norms of act as well then you can do all
right so next I want to tell you a
little bit about how this actually works
and before I so I'm gonna actually give
you the whole scheme now and it won't
make much sense but then hopefully in
the next few minutes I'll explain why
you know why it makes sense how did it
actually come about okay so in our
scheme we're gonna have a bunch of
different hash tables okay a bunch of
different hash functions each coming
from a different hash family so you have
hash family h1 h2 HD okay so you know
here's a hash table that's built using
the first one here the hash table is
built using the second one and here's
the hash table built using the last one
in each case these are hash families we
pick a hash function from the family and
we build a hash table using that alright
so you have these hash tables hash
families each of them has a collision
probability what is the collision
probably it's just the probability that
two points end up in the same hash
bucket so each of them has a different
behavior for their collision
probabilities okay and then we also have
some funky weight functions so what's
gonna happen is you know this is the
quantity that we really want to compute
we're gonna sum up we're gonna express
this as a sum over R T hash tables and
our th hash table is is gonna be
responsible for this portion right so
we're gonna take our the quantity that
we wanted and actually distributed over
the T hash tables and say okay T hash
table is responsible for this piece yeah
we're gonna sum up the contributions of
these guys so yeah so what what do we do
for to pre-process we choose hash
functions from our families we build our
hash tables
taking a data set and just populating
these ash tables when the query comes
along we're gonna say where the query
lands in each of these hash tables okay
so it's hash bucket one hash bucket two
hash bucket te okay from each of these
hash buckets we're going to pull out a
random element that falls in that hash
bucket okay
that's XD so these are the samples from
the hash buckets and then what we're
gonna do is okay for the T attached
table we're gonna say what's the weight
attached to this particular sample
that's this quantity here but then we're
gonna do some bias correction there a
bias corrected by dividing by the
probability that that Y and XT collided
and we're also going to multiply with
the size of the hash bucket sum up over
the T hash tables right that's what
we're gonna do as I said that's the
scheme it's here and I wrote it down
here so we have it but now I'm going to
explain why this makes sense all right
so the key point is that this quantity
here this one same thing is actually an
unbiased estimator of thing that we care
about and the crux of the analysis is
setting this thing up so we can actually
say something about the variance of this
quantity right so we can actually bound
things like how many hash tables we need
and so and so forth that's where all the
work is okay so that's the setup right
this is exactly what we're gonna do any
questions
I told we call this multi-resolution
hashing based estimators the reason is
because the term hashing base estimators
already exists
tell you what it is in a second some of
the challenges in doing this is so we
are sort of figured out you know I I
have these d different hash tables what
are they doing how do we distribute
these weights across the hash tables I
said each hash table is responsible for
some portion so how do we do that you
know what are these hash functions
exactly what are the collision
probabilities and and finally how do we
bound the variance of this whole thing
it sounds pretty complicated ok so
that's sort of what what happens in the
answers let me give you some of the some
ideas in proof so let's start with a
very baby version okay so a baby version
is the following
suppose we have a bunch of weights w1 WN
and you know you think of these weights
as exactly that the function that you're
summing up over your endpoints so these
are n weights and I want to approximate
the sum of these n weights or the
average of T and let's just think about
the sum of the N means one way to do
this is just a sample point I not really
uniform distribution with some current
biased distributed sample point I with
probability Q I let's say I have some
such sampling probabilities available to
me if I report WI by Q I then this is an
unbiased estimator of the sum
this thing of the uniform case when all
of the queue is our one over N we sample
one of the wiU report n times WI well
that's an unbiased estimator of the some
of it of yours
in general you might want to choose a
bias distribution to reduce the variance
of this estimator just a well-known
method important sampling in fact the
best way to choose these widths these
probabilities is exactly so that qi is
proportional to W it okay if you could
actually design such a sampling
distribution that's great this will
actually give you a low variance
estimator and that's the sort of the
basis for our scheme the challenge by
the way in our scheme is that these
weights are dependent on the query Y
right so so we want to design a sampling
distribution which is somehow controlled
by our query right it's not a fixed
thing so you want to design a method
which can support different sampling
probabilities which change depending on
the query okay all right so how do you
do that well there's this method of
hashing called the calorie sensitive
hashing is the co-inventors is out here
in the audience Puranic building on you
know line of a nice work in the theory
literature so what's the idea the idea
is that you take space and you somehow
chop it up into pieces in some nice way
and the idea is that the probability
that two points fall in the same piece
is somehow a function of their distance
things are nearby
tend to fall in same piece things that
are far away tend to fall at different
pieces so there's some collision
probability which is distance dependent
okay and this was this idea was used
actually in joint work with Paris that
we had just before the severan fox we
said is that if you actually have such a
hashing scheme you can design estimators
for the kinds of quantities that I
talked about
they're the idea what the there is that
we had was if we can design a hashing
scheme such that the collision
probability behaves like square root of
the function that you're trying to sum
up okay then you can design an estimator
that has the right expectation and the
relative variance is 1 over root what is
the relative balance relative variance
is just the ratio of the variance to the
expectation squared okay so if you apply
chebyshev and you say how many copies of
this estimator do you need to get low
low error it's just a relative variance
that controls how many copies you need
so actually you want to get something
with low relative variance so anyway
this means that we need 1 over root in
your copy so our sample complexity is 1
over root the key thing is that so
anyway this this was our scheme okay so
what was our scheme a scheme was we have
1 hash family which has this magic
property that somehow the collision
probability is close to square root of
the function that we want we design our
hash table using this nice family that
we found and then we sample a random
point from this family okay we compute
the the contribution of that point to
our sum this and we weighted by the
inverse forward we do exactly the
important sampling yeah what is the
probability that we actually picked this
point x well two things need to happen
one is X needs to have collided with Y
the probably that happening is P X Y
okay but then in that hash bucket there
are a bunch of other fellows over
sitting in there as well and of all of
them you need to have picked this guy X
so the probability of sampling X is the
probability divided by the size of the
hash bucket so this is exactly the
important sampling correction sorry this
is unbiased and you can actually analyze
the variance itself etc which is what we
did before okay okay
this scale-free property is actually a
little hard to attain and in fact we can
do this for some nice function the
Gaussian function
exponential function and the polynomial
deviations regime because we've got e to
the minus something about exponential
transforms I'm not sure actually I
should chat with you after yeah I'd love
to chat with you after so Eddy reminds
me they have two minutes which is a lot
lower than I thought I did but I'm gonna
try to give you a rough idea what we do
okay so I said this was the scheme I
haven't actually told you how we got it
but let me tell you what goes into this
okay so few things we want to somehow
take this idea we had before and
generalize it to multiple resolutions
and I'll say what that means we use
something called distance sensitive
hashing and maybe I'll tell you what
that means and then maybe I won't say
anything or the last thing okay so so
let me just give you the intuition maybe
that's all I'll tell you here's the
intuition so here's our function that we
want to estimate this is our Phi we want
to we chop this up into little pieces
okay so think of approximating Phi by in
in this way let's look at one of these
pieces a little step function
we're gonna have essentially a hash
table that's devoted to computing each
of these little pieces okay and that's
where we get our multiple high families
now in order to do this we're gonna need
a hash function which is somehow able to
focus on points that I have a particular
inner product right so I said we're
going to design hash functions which
somehow are responsible for computing
this function this means that they need
to have high collision probability for
things that are sort of in this range
and they drop off now thankfully for us
there are such hashing schemes okay so
so we just rely on prior work that
actually design such a hashing scheme
and don't read anything into this this
is far too complicated to understand in
a minute but so there is a method by
which you can design distance sensitive
hashing schemes where the collision
probability can be designed to peak at
exactly the point that you want now you
pay dearly if you really want a designs
hashing scheme so the peak is very tight
okay so it's possible this is what we
leverage and then somehow we put all
this together and figure out what's the
variance of this now this seems like a
real mess but it turns out that if we
set our weights correctly the one other
thing that I had was these weights if I
set my weights correctly then analyzing
the variance of this is very nice it
just turns out - it falls into analyzing
variance corresponding to the upper
envelope of these functions what I'm
saying above it makes no sense
whatsoever if you read our paper
hopefully it'll make sense I think I'm
Way over time so I should stop now you
can just this is just to show you
there's some cool things in there that I
didn't tell you about and you can find
it all about if you look at our paper so
anyway
[Music]
where'd I talk about you know estimating
things partition functions like that we
use these hash functions that are
designed to peek at certain points and
fall off and then we somehow approximate
our function by a collection of other
functions there's some technical videos
in there that I didn't actually talk
about those are our email addresses if
you like to find out more
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a key point on that slide future
work yes you know it's it's something
that's been on my to-do list for a while
but we haven't done it yet